the show in Abu
Dhabi was insane really it was insane
and I didn't edit anything that's what I
wanted to ask how were they about
flagrancy oh they were loving it there
was one joke that I was concerned about
and I don't want to say it but I'm sure
if anybody's seen the life tour they
probably aware of it and uh there was
one joke and in the moment I was like I
don't know and I was like it I'll
just do it and they exploded
really whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa not like
that yeah yeah yeah good point good
point they exploded there's no more at
more sensitive no no it was it was crazy
and uh yeah the Emirates is is just it's
really interesting like everybody there
like all the locals they went to school
in America somewhere or they went to
school in England so like they're fluent
English is perfect and they are aware of
all like the cultural stuff like they've
experienced the cultural stuff so like
it was probably that was probably our
most fluent American audience really in
American culture in American culture
yeah yeah yeah yeah London as well but I
was shocked cuz I think we all went into
it going I don't know what they're going
to find funny I don't know what's going
on you also have the guys in the robes
the koras they're called like so you're
thinking okay are they going to get all
these things but all those dudes went to
school in America and they didn't go to
school in like New York they went to
school in like Alabama cville Tennesse
Tennessee Arkansas like so they're
really aware of it yeah and um yeah it
was it was fun I didn't edit
anything fire yeah it was really cool it
was really cool yeah I'll get hit up
sometimes be like hey you got to come to
Dubai to do a show and I'm like no that
seems crazy why would I do that seems
dangerous and they will always say no
you don't get it we're way more down
than you think it's cool to know yeah it
was far I think way more down like they
cuz they don't get it necessarily like
they don't get that type of thing not
that many people go there and the people
that do go there I think go with this
conception oh this is like a very
conservative Muslim country like you
can't do the certain things you would
normally do and so I think people
probably button it up whereas they're
like yo we and they also tell you like
there's like five different versions of
what you can or can't say okay you know
the promoters are saying one thing but
the promoters might be from outside of
the Emirates so they're worried about
their reputation so like don't touch
about these things and then you talk to
the people there on that side they're
like yeah yeah kind of you know say
whatever you want like they're like
listen don't trash Islam that's not a
good idea but you know have jokes do
whatever and um but the audience is like
I mean like women hijabis women in the
hijab just dying laughing at
so it was it was very cool people are
people bro yeah people are people they
just like jokes if it's funny if it's
and yeah to what you said I do think
there's a thing where the more like
constrictive a culture is the more the
comedy club is the Haven where everybody
can come laugh like it's different but
we talk about Portland and you'll say
like the audiences love the offensive
jokes CU outside none of that is allowed
so we go to this place where now I can
finally hear it let's go I'm dying
especially if it's like if it's with
love yeah you did a good job though you
didn't go up and just just be like hey
here are my jokes the first 15 minutes
he's talking about deep cut like I'm
sure you're going to put Clips out from
it right you're talking about like deep
cut things that like you only know if
you grew up in Abu Dhabi yeah like even
people from Dubai were like oh wait how
like it's so nuanced it's so Niche
there's a guy sitting in front of us at
the show while we were watching and the
whole time he's just like how does he
know this like he's like touching the
people next to him he's like like how
did he figure this out like like
speaking in Arabic words that they were
like this isn't S so you did a good job
probably being inserted into the culture
and I think like if they see that then
then they know that you're not coming
there just judging them and you know
basically criticizing all their
that's different from yours they're like
okay you took a little second to you
absorb what's going on and then I think
they give you you know the longest leash
the you know they're the most open about
anything else you say because you're not
coming through with that critical lens
right right right the intention is good
he took the time to learn about us yeah
yeah like it was some yeah it was fun so
I'll put some clips out for it but there
yeah there's some fun there was some fun
it was fire bro our hotel in Abu
Dhabi was literally in the middle of the
F1 track yeah holy
iack and like I there's a b my bathroom
that where I would take a I look
out the window and that's where the F1
cars and everything go and we got on the
F1 TR that was fire that was
crazy so instead of roosters you just
hear and I wakes you
up yeah you think it's awesome you get
you're like dude we're on the track and
then like 10: a.m. it's
just yeah yeah we could move the
schedule a little bit yeah but dude it
was so cool are we going to share some
of the people that came to the show oh
yeah yeah yeah I don't I don't know what
the rule with that is but before the
show starts there's one of the promoters
that's there and I'm going through all
my jokes being like is any of this funny
is any of this going to work do they
know what this means at all I'm like so
stressed I'm only doing like 12 15
minutes but I'm like so so anxious and I
talked to the promoter and she looked
super nervous and I'm like wait what's
what's going on and she's like well um
uh one one of the the members of the
royal family uh that's uh a little bit
higher up in the family than we
anticipated showed up tonight
and we didn't anticipate them to be here
we expected some of like the lower
levels of the family to be here did you
know this we didn't tell no one told
like issue and so they're like yeah you
know one of the members of the royal
family and again United Arab Emirates is
controlled by basically one royal family
like all every different Emirate has a
royal family like came basally seven
different tribes that got organized by
one guy right and that guy was from Abu
Dhabi Abu Dhabi is where all the the
real money is yeah they have oil still
they have gas still Dubai doesn't have
any oil or gas and whole bet in Dubai
was yo let's turn into like a tourism
Hub because we're going to run out of
the oil and gas but originally these
were all their individual tribes and
they're organized by Zed what's his name
uh shik zed shik zed and uh and he
convinced a bunch of these other tribes
to lock in now there's a few that didn't
I don't think Oman decided not to
they're like we'll do our own thing it's
like Stringer Bell for oil right exactly
cut bah cutter bahin they decide not to
but then the other ones got down but so
we're sitting there I'm talking to the
girl I'm like okay on level like one
being like the biggest dude and 10 being
like a lower level person like what
would you rate it she was like uh
probably like three or four and so
we're like okay and so we're going
through the jokes like he's going
through jokes like should I say this one
should I do this one and then I don't
know if it's going to be xats or locals
yeah and by locals that means you have
to be born as an emirati you're not born
there like you have to be part of the
andat people who move from the US too
right no okay the opposite so you have
to be like from there you're tribal from
there and then an xat that moves there
is not considered a local yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying an X fat is
someone who comes from somewhere else
yes yes yes so then we do the show the
show's amazing then afterwards the
promoter like kind of comes up to Dove
and Andrew and they're like um members
of the royal family would like to meet
you crazy what are you thinking in this
moment cuz you didn't even know they
were there anybody I see in the kandora
I assume is the royal
family it's really amazing no it's it's
an amazing way that like when everybody
puts on the outfit you just kind of
assume so you don't know and the Royal
doesn't get like a stick or anything to
let you know that they're you know what
I mean
so it's kind of that way where anybody
you see is dressed the same so the flex
happens in another way not just the
clothing right where like obviously you
know in in America or something else
like we're flexing right um oh they
don't have a bunch of logos on there and
like think Su Cree candora so I was
giving Royal Treatment to some bums
probably you know what I'm saying I'm
seeing a candora I'm like what's up man
how you doing and uh it's nerve-racking
they yeah the worldes are going to come
back we're not allowed to say no to them
if they want to meet you like that's
kind of the rule and imagine saying no
I'm good they're coming back right now
and uh yeah they would like to speak
with you and then the dude comes back
and what happens I think yeah I think
that I yeah I think it was just it was
Vibes it was fun the nicest guy he's
like 20-year-old dude super sweet huge
fan of Comedy love Schultz had the best
time of the show brought all his boys
and we just it was just yeah it was fun
and all of these things that I made up
in my head of like oh they're going to
be this and conservative they were just
like they're kids we just like jokes we
just like hanging out with the boys
they're just
yeah it was crazy we went out to get
some food they're like hey do you want
to come back to our Palace and play
FIFA and we're like Mark's dream dude
immed yeah we would we would like to do
that a lot of fun I started instigating
dud we were talking I was like dude
I'm G to watch you in FIFA if I beat you
in FIFA I get citizenship I'm going to
sports
watching yeah bro it was crazy it was so
fun and then he had one of the most
insane comebacks in FIFA history oh yeah
I couldn't let them beat me bro you
can't do that dude I mean he beat me but
it was penalty kicks bro penalty kicks
it was penalty kicks wa you were
bragging about a loss here but it was a
good comeback though that's a Schult
Winn is a is a show win right there no
it was just fun like it was it was cool
like learning little things about the
spot like like I didn't understand the
whole license plate have you heard
about this thing where like license
plates are incredibly expensive there so
the smaller the number it's like yeah
okay the higher they are or or it's just
more expensive right and it's like if
you buy someone bought number three for
like $10 million or some like that
and I was like yo what's the deal with
this cuz I didn't understand it I was
like it seems like such a flagrant waste
of money and uh one of the kids was like
yo when everybody has a G wagon like it
ain't a flex yeah and people are going
to find their ways to flex outside of
just having a G wagon so it's the
license plate number and then then he
was like and now what's happening is if
if people don't want you to know who
they are they buy a shitty number mhm so
if you got real money
the way of kind of like making your
identity a little bit more obscure is to
not have the low number and is that its
own Flex like people who buy designer
clothes in America and they're like I
don't want the logo on it at all whereas
when you first get money you're like I
want the logo everywhere know got this
and you got understand like they first
getting money we're talking about like
they've been You Know Rich for 50 years
yeah yeah they've only been a country
for like 70 yeah yeah yeah so like
they're still learning how to deal with
money what to spend it on where you
invest like what kids are going to do
with their life like it's just I don't
know it was just a very interesting
thing I had I had no expectation really
going in into it I was like okay it's
just going to be big Glitz glamour
hotels are crazy superlex Etc and then
just getting into like the nuances of
the culture I thought was kind of cool
can you explain that some some people
had a license play more expensive than
the car like some people had a Nissan
yeah yeah yeah yeah they they told me
that like back in the day that during
the war like they sided with uh uh
Kuwait I guess against Iraq mhm and and
uh the guy who had like the Nissan
dealership rights in the country
basically like gave the Army Nissans so
now Nissan is like a beloved brand there
so everybody gets these Nissan and as a
way to just you know show respect but
then you put the super high license
plate on it so you let people know like
yo I don't have to have a Nissan yeah
you know what I mean I got it and uh bro
they were saying like dating is wild
like you can't just take a girl to your
house because obviously it's strict
Muslim rules like your mom is going to
tell tell their mom there's only a
million Emirates so uh what they do is
they'll like have their first dates and
they'll like mall parking
lots so you basically get the SUV that
can get folded back ah and then you go
to a mall parking lot and that's your
date and you can't go to the
hotel cuz every Hotel you got to show
your ID and that will get back to Mom
and Pops potentially so they got to find
all these workarounds for the system
when they're not banging out Russian
hookers and yeah yeah no it was
cool bro it was awesome shamis can you
explain that I don't even know how yeah
man we'll put out all the clips and
everything like that but but yeah it was
really cool I'm excited for everybody to
see it also you sign up at price.com and
use the promo code Schultz they will
match your initial deposit up to $100